you're about to meet the greatest
warriors the world has ever known
legendary
fashionable
powerful
well i'm sure that was a lot of fun for
you it was on november 5th the marvel
universe play nice becomes eternal so
what's your superpower
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked right
marvel studios eat turn off sweetie
pg-13 only theaters november 5th welcome
back everyone this will be my new
eternals trailer video they released a
bunch of new footage just hyping up
their powers and comparing them to the
avengers like they joke in the trailer
you're about to meet the greatest
warriors the world has ever known also
explain what the powers of kit
harrington's black knight character are
that he gets through the ebony blade so
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're gonna have a bunch of eternal
stuff happening really soon because the
movie's coming out in a couple weeks
they're using the movie to broaden the
marvel cosmic universe the cosmic level
characters but also set up a lot of
future marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5
story like mutants the x-men characters
and more major cosmic threats like you
saw during the shangshi movie during the
shangxi post-credits scene they just
hype a big cosmic threat through the 10
rings from another dimension so if
you're a big fan of the cosmic level
storytelling that you've seen so far in
the mcu they're going to be rolling hard
on that heading into avengers 5. but
like i said this brand new trailer is
about comparing their team to the
avengers team that's why kingo is joking
in the trailer talking to his cameraman
saying you're about to meet the greatest
warriors the world has ever known and
most fashionable marvel is also calling
this trailer the team trailer like the
eternals team compared to the avengers
team so it's just a funny way of showing
how some of the eternals characters
think of themselves as being on a level
way beyond the avengers because of who
they are where they come from and how
they were created thank you for this oh
you're welcome so now that captain
rogers and iron man are both gone who do
you think's gonna lead the avengers
i could lead them
[Music]
i know there's a big question about
who's more powerful the eternals or the
avengers who would win in a fight i will
address that because it largely depends
on who's on that avengers team the
eternals are this really weird bunch of
characters from the comics they've only
crossed over with the actual avengers a
couple times i know a lot of people have
since asked me too on some of my other
eternals videos is galactus the one
that's growing inside planet earth and
no i don't think that's the case i mean
it would be really cool but galactus is
a completely different type of character
who was created in a very different type
of way he's as old as the universe it
seems that they're going to wait till
after the new fantastic four movie to
introduce mcu galactus and they'll
probably go with a more comic book
accurate backstory for his character
with a couple minor twists but then the
rest of the trailer is mostly dedicated
to giving you a tutorial on their powers
and how their abilities work and how
they're different from each other the
funny thing in the comics is that
actually most of their powers in the
comics are pretty much the same they had
to change that for the movie so they
just kind of seem like different
characters and different personalities
if we're actually comparing them to the
avengers like this trailer is doing
they're way more similar to each other
than the avengers because most of the
avengers come from very different races
different parts of the galaxy and the
avengers have mostly wildly different
powers and different power levels like
you have the ground level heroes who are
just normal people like hawkeye and
black widow on the team with cosmic gods
like thor whereas the eternals are all
cut from the same celestial cloth so to
speak and a lot of their passive
abilities are the same it's just for the
purposes of the movie they give them a
couple different active powers so that
when they're all fighting together as a
team like they have their big avengers
assemble moments in the trailers it
doesn't look super boring the passive
abilities that they share are that
they're all functionally immortal
because of the way the celestials
created them to have perfect biology
they're not human they're just celestial
creations made to look human so that
they can blend in on earth during their
mission that's how you get to people
like thanos who's an eternal from titan
like his parents are eternals but they
look very different from the eternals
that were sent to earth i don't know if
they're going to completely get into the
whole reincarnation thing during the
movie they might just skip over that
because it seems like if any of them die
during the movie it's not going to be
till present day i know there are all
kinds of theories about salma hayek's
character ajax because you don't see her
anywhere in any of the other present-day
fight scenes like what happens to her
after she starts talking about the
emergence and putting the team together
as they say in the movie though they're
about 7 000 years old when they pick up
in present day they all use celestial
energy cosmic energy is the source of
their powers and abilities that's why
all their powers manifest with that
yellow energy there are two different
timelines in the movie or two different
story periods part of the story takes
place in the past and explains how they
were created what their full backstory
is why they were created and shows them
running around the earth as a full team
wrecking the deviants like in full blown
avengers assemble mode like you saw in
the avengers movies thus the comparison
to the avengers then the other time
period they explore is in present day
after the blip after avengers end game
when the emergence is about to happen
when the team has been living apart for
hundreds of years just living amongst
humans all doing their own thing none of
them have spoken to each other for
hundreds of years when the movie picks
up because for a long time crow and the
deviants have gone dormant the eternal's
assistance wasn't really required as
much not counting all the regular wars
and events of the infinity saga movies
because as they explained ayrshin the
judge and the celestial host made them
take a knee for all those things the
other trailers have given us a pretty
good idea for what's going on with all
the members of the team when icarus
starts going around in present day
trying to do his own avengers assemble
2.0 as you can see with all the other
references they make to the avengers
this is all meant to be a parallel for
the events of captain america civil war
through avengers end game with the
avengers breaking up for a while so to
speak a great calamity happening thanos
in the snap and then them bringing the
team back together during avengers end
game the eternals are basically having
their own version of that it's another
world ending threat the emergence this
celestial that's threatening to emerge
from planet earth and destroy the planet
the deviants separately they're trying
to kill humans in the third threat in
the celestial host airship the judge
coming to earth to destroy it if the
emergence doesn't go as the celestials
had planned it to so here we go again
just a bunch of other world ending
disasters but going around the team just
talking about their major different
powers icarus can fly and shoot energy
beams from his eyes thus all the
superman jokes vision also kind of has
his own version of this except his
energy beams come out of his forehead
because of the mind stone or if you're
talking about white vision is the
focusing crystal in his forehead cersei
can transmute matter that's why you see
her turning the bus into flowers turning
the dirt into water turning the volcanic
rocks into birds during this big final
battle here she can also communicate
directly with the celestials in a way
the others can't that's kind of what's
going on during this scene she's
communicating with irishman the judge
getting orders from him ajax powers
manifests a little bit like dr strange's
magical shields and projectiles but
kingo can give off energy bursts and
smaller projectiles you kind of see him
doing a hadouken on one of these
deviants fastos is their engineer he
creates things like they have the
vibranium joke at the end of that last
trailer but his innate power manifests
more like complex drones athena
manifests that wicked celestial pole arm
weapon gilgamesh is kind of like their
version of the hulk making more avengers
comparisons he's the most physically
powerful one he's kind of like their
brawler like a tank if you want to think
of them as a raiding party you can see
him reinforcing his arms with celestial
shields around them as he starts
brawling with one of these deviants
sprite creates illusions kind of like
loki's illusions and even though she
looks like a little kid all of the
eternals are the exact same age the
reason why the celestials created them
to look different is just to help them
blend in with the people on planet earth
this also gets into the idea of what's
going on with makari so she's their
speedster she has super speed it's
pretty self-explanatory notice the way
they visualize her super speed powers to
be different from the way that mcu
quicksilver speed looks in the way that
x-men quicksilver's power looks you
could also make comparisons to the flash
in the way they visualize his speed too
she's also deaf she's being played by a
deaf actress and they will explain in
the movie why she is deaf because why
would the celestials create them to have
perfect biology then give one of them a
disability they'll explain what happened
with that during the course of the film
druid is telepathic and control people's
minds you kind of see him doing that
with his weird little cult that he's
living with in present day when they go
to try and bring him back for the
emergence he's kind of like the loki of
the family the true black sheep then
even though kit harrington's black
knight character is not an eternal his
powers all come from the ebony blade
that's passed down through this family
line the blade comes from the king
arthur camelot era of history marvel
does have their own version of those
characters so in the main mcu universe
king arthur was a real person camelot
was a real place the blade is heavily
enchanted with a bunch of different
abilities but carries a powerful curse
it's kind of like a stormbreaker level
weapon with many different powers when
the black knight is wielding the blade
as long as some part of his body is
touching it he can't be killed he can
also use it to teleport but it's more
like doctor strange's portals not like
stormbreaker opening bifrost wormholes
and he doesn't need to be touching the
blade in order to teleport he can
teleport himself to the blaze location
and he can bring the blade to him he can
summon it the way that thor summons his
hammer and stormbreaker the blade also
protects him from most magical attacks
so like dr strange's magic maybe even
scarlet witch's chaos magic wouldn't
affect him as much when the blade is on
him it can also feed on the souls of
people it kills to enhance its powers
but this also ties in with the curse
that it carries the blade draws out the
negative emotions of the wielder and the
more people you kill with it the more it
fills you with the berserker blood rage
so eventually you can lose yourself so
to speak to the blade if you've ever
read the berserk manga or watch the
anime it's kind of like the berserker
armor super powerful but also kind of
works against you if you're not careful
that's why i say you can lose yourself
to the blade like eventually the black
knight if he succumbed to the curse he
would turn on all the other allies that
he's working with and try to kill them
too for those of you asking who would
win in a fight if the eternals actually
fought the avengers so the only way the
avengers would have a chance of beating
them because they're so powerful with
the celestial technology the way that
they're functionally immortal would be
if the avengers had all their most
powerful members on the team like you'd
have to have thor with stormbreaker
you'd have to have the hulk and it'd
have to be world breaker hulk you'd have
to have scarlet witch with her chaos
magic doctor strange captain marvel and
iron man and reed richards would have to
be there and have to have figured out
how celestial energy works and found a
way to counter it with their technology
or use it against the eternals but you
can still kill the eternals like you can
still destroy their bodies they also
have a lot of the petty squabbles that
the avengers have like they also break
up as a team for a period of time
what did i tell you would happen
if you ate the last donut with red white
and blue sprinkles a little foggy on it
but i think it was something like
raining down hellfire but if you have
any big questions about what's going on
with their characters or how their
powers work just write them below in the
comments and i'll try to address them
with my future bonus videos and we'll
get a brand new spider-man no way home
trailer pretty soon probably a doctor
strange 2 trailer in the next couple of
months as well there's a low-key game of
thrones reunion happening in the
eternals movie with jon snow and rob
stark i just did a big house of the
dragon trailer and easter eggs video for
the game of thrones prequel series click
here for that video and click here for
my full marvel what if episode 9 finale
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]